we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a sad voicemail
this is a supposed progressive who's
canceling me he's saying he's
unsubscribing
because i refuse to lie to him this
viewer
wants me to lie to him and because i
won't
he's unsubscribing take a listen to this
this is very sad very very sad
david i think you're very smart
uh honest
and i agree with you most of the time
but i just had to unsubscribe and stop
listening because you are normalizing
trump's criminal behavior
and trump's crimes every time you say
trump will never be indicted
for a felony or never
you know go to jail or prison for a
felony that's normalizing what he does
and no no no no no
it's telling the truth
it's telling the truth trump's not going
to go to prison for anything he did
while president he's not going to i'm
not going to lie to you it's not
progressive to lie to you and
you're just too intelligent for that and
it really angers me
wow
and i i'm
my political perspective is i am a
very progressive democrat
that's fine but why would you want me to
lie to you then
um
i really think you should rethink
telling your
viewers that that trump will never be
indicted or never go to prison well
there's really nothing to rethink the
question is
what do i think he will go to prison and
remember i never said he wouldn't be
indicted i said trump is not going to
see the inside of a jail cell or a
prison cell that's what i said i believe
that's the truth i don't lie to people
on this show i don't tell people things
because it's what they want to hear i'm
not going to give you false hope
it's conceivable that trump's business
will be sanctioned it's conceivable that
some of the people around trump will be
indicted it's i guess conceivable trump
might be indicted but trump isn't going
to prison and i am not going to fuel
people in my audience imagining that
we're going to see trump in an orange
jumpsuit
in cuffs because we're not going to see
it and so if you're looking for a show
that will
tell you things that are untrue
there's many of them available but
that's not the way i do things on this
program it's just a fantasy
it's not progressive
to say things that aren't true
because progressives would like to see
those things happen i would be doing
everybody a disservice if i did that so
uh the complaint is i'm not willing to
lie to you guys and you know what
guilty is charged i'm gonna tell you
things the way i see them we've got a
great bonus show for you today
california has launched an investigation
into larry elder uh larry elder's
financial disclosure larry elder is
running for the california gubernatorial
recall election we'll talk about that
nasa would like to get back to the moon
by 2024. unfortunately the new
generation space suits won't be ready
and this may end up being
the first in potentially many
delays with getting back to the moon by
2024 and we will talk about a new report
very disturbing and important report
that facebook's most viewed article in
early 2021
was one casting doubt on the covet
vaccine
and the degree to which facebook is tied
in with the uncontrolled spread of
misinformation disinformation and
conspiracy theories is horrifying quite
frankly so we're going to look at all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show make sure you get instant access
by signing up at joinpackman.com
if you'd rather do it via patreon we are
on patreon as well and you can find us
at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have a
fantastic week for you this week we've
got great interviews we're going to try
a slightly different format
for the friday show and so many things
going on it's great to be back and we
will see you in mere moments on the
bonus show